wunderschönen guten morgen mein name ist
wie zuletzt und äcker ich bin am 4
einsatzleiter beim jagd kommando wir
befinden uns hier gerade am attersee der
attersee ist einer unserer dach städten
bzw
trainingsorte für unsere dach und
kampfschwimmer und wir befinden uns
jetzt gerade in einer fort- und
weiterbildung für kampf schwimmer und
taucher vom ja kommando und die darf ich
heute durch oder durchführen durch einen
tag unserer ausbildung und in diesem
zuge würde ich gern mal die ausrüstung
vorstellen die wir benutzen wir schauen
uns genau an vorbereiten der ausrüstung
eines pressluft beziehungsweise
arbeitstages wir haben jetzt
verschiedene ausrüstungsgegenstände
wir haben natürlich was man immer mit
haben jeder bei uns ist ein messer das
war am unterschenkel tagen deshalb für
diverse arbeiten brauchen oder zum
beispiel wenn man aus irgend einer
notsituation heraus schneiden müssen
dann haben wir verschiedene instrumente
wir haben einmal die richtung wir haben
die zeit und wir haben die tiefe und
zusätzlich dr pressluft oder arbeitstag
einen tag computer mit sich dann aber
die flossen flossen noch mal
verschiedene flusssystems systeme bei
uns bleiben bei den dafür genannt
eingeführt da arbeitstage hatte er eine
kleinere flüsse der stationär im gesetz
der brauchen jetzt schnell oder
effektivität von a nach b bewegen so
eine flosse sollten eigentlich nicht im
weg senden da nochmal natürlich
handschuhe dabei vor allem jetzt um
diese jahreszeit im attersee dann haben
wir einen anzug einen guten tag und zug
der arbeitstage benutzt haben darin
zukaufs der bleibt ihnen drohten er kann
eigentlich ganz normal mit seiner
uniform darunter die charta 77 auf unter
diesen wochentag und zu garen und er
bleibt trocken und natürlich
dementsprechend geworden wir haben jetzt
da das funksystem dass der euro stärker
benutzt mit dem funksystem haben die
möglichkeit unter wasser funksystem
aufzubauen beziehungsweise dort von
taucha funk verbindung herzustellen aber
auch vom taucher und die oberfläche funk
verbindung herzustellen reichweite haben
mit diesem gerät maximal horizontal 1000
meter und in die tiefe ungefähr 90 meter
ist aber von verschiedenen unterwasser
faktoren abhängig dann haben wir hier
unseren
pressluftflasche 300 bar in dem fall ist
es ein doppelblock
und dann haben wir da dieses wind jacket
das jetzt dann versuchen wird mit der
flasche und
das der dass der arbeitstag quasi am
montag der arbeitstag hat genutzt eine
voll gesichtsmaske das heißt dass das
ganze gesicht ist abgedeckt und er kann
natürlich dann in verbindung mit funk
ganz normal sprechen wir haben ein
offenes system offenes system heißt das
der
luft aus der flasche bezieht und daran
die ausatemluft in die umgebung wieder
abgibt das heißt er produziert bisschen
und die sieht nur dann an der oberfläche
was wir morgen komplett egal ist weil er
ja eine taktisch unterwegs ist okay dann
schauen wir uns an die ausrüstung eines
kampffliegers
die ausrüstung des filmes unterscheidet
sich natürlich wesentlich ihnen in der
art und weise im vergleich zum bereits
vor der presse oft auch wir beginnen
hier natürlich mit der bewaffnung die
kampfschwimmer mit sich führt wir haben
da einmal die fnp 90 im kaliber 57 mit
einem 50 schuss magazin auf der woche
drauf haben ein taktisches licht laser
modul und eine zielhilfe da noch einmal
als backup bewaffnung haben wir unsere
köpfe närrischen 5 und am taktischen
gurt diverse ausrüstungsgegenstände
wie die lederman und reserve magazine
messer doktor kampfschwimmer natürlich
auch bei sich nicht unter wasser in ein
gefecht aufzutragen mit einem
miteinander kampf führen sondern
ebenfalls ruhen sich aus einer situation
heraus zu schneiden wenn jetzt überlegen
wohin bleibt da mal wieder eines unserer
flotte systeme unterscheidet sich
ebenfalls zu dem zudem klose von der
norweger mit denen kann ich sehr sehr
gut und effizient über längere strecken
schwimmen und mehr fortbewegen
was dr kampfschwimmer jetzt für
bekleidung wir haben dazu hier den einen
nasdaq und zug nostalgiezug aus neopren
er heißt es im inneren aus dass es ist
jetzt in
es ist immer ein bisserl kälter was aber
egal ist weil er durchgehend in bewegung
ist
daran hat er kaum schwimmer mit ihnen
eine handfeste bzw einem flotten träger
kugel schutzweste wo die wir die werte
ausrüstungsgegenstände taktische
ausrüstungsgegenstände drinnen versorgt
werden wir haben damals unsere reserven
magazine für die p90 wir haben auf der
linken seite des magic beck da ist die
erste hilfe ausrüstung drinnen und sehr
markant beim amphibischen platten träger
ist dass wir not auftriebshilfen rechts
und links haben die den kampf um
möglichen aus einer notsituation sehr
schnell die oberfläche zu gewinnen
jetzt kommen wir zu unserem kreis auf
gerät das kreislauf gerät benutzt
benutzt der kampfschwimmer um eben unter
wasser zu tauchen bei dem kreislauf
gerät handelt sich um ein geschlossenes
system geschlossenes system heißt dass
wir keine ausatemluft in die umgebung
abgeben das heißt es entstehen keine
verräterischen bläschen an der
oberfläche wir haben ganz grob erklärt
wir haben einen ein arten und einen aus
harten schlag wir haben ein mundstück
wir haben eine gegen junge in dem system
und wir haben einen behälter wir
brauchen den atem kalkum das co2 aus der
ausatemluft herauszufiltern und dann
ganz unten im gerät haben wir eine
1,5 liter sauerstoff flaschen wie der
name schon sagt das ist 100 prozentiger
sauerstoff drinnen und mit dieser
flasche 15 liter kampfschwimmer ungefähr
4,5 oder 45 stunden unter wasser sich
fortbewegen
okay wir sind jetzt bei der praktischen
ausbildung unseres heutigen trainings
angelangt und wir sehen da im
hintergrund einen arbeitstag druck der
sich gerade den lask durchführt und dann
wasser der arbeitsmarktreport heute
einen auftrag eine reichweite eine
überprüfung mit dem unterwasser
funkgerät durchzuführen auf dauer wird
ungefähr 20 60 minuten und die
tauchtiefe 23 meter
wie kommt es überhaupt zu der nach
ausbildung oder wie wird man beim land
oder kaum schüler beim kommando
grundsätzlich relativ easy man meldet
sich zum auswahlverfahren und machte den
jargon der grundkurs nach
abgeschlossenem yorker maler grundkurs
beginnt dann der grund auf kurs der
grund auch kurs dauert drei monate und
einem grundkurs lernt man überhaupt noch
mit einer starken das umgehen mit dem
ressort gerät und man hat dann mit
positiven abschluss die qualifikation
leichte arbeiten unter wasser
durchzuführen und auch suchen werden
retten
danach folgt dann der kampf für markus
kampfschwimmer kursdauer dann ein halbes
jahr und dann kam schlimmer kurs lernt
man dann das tauchen mit dem kreis auf
geräten mit dem träger gerät und man
lernt dann sich taktisch im wasser zu
bewegen bzw das wasser taktisch
auszunutzen man lernt dass er inter
vertiefen man lernt das lautlose
annähern an verschiedenen objekten und
verlernt das taktische anlanden und
alles was jetzt im ganzen und großem
rahmen damit zusammen
und jetzt im anschluss schauen wir uns
einen kampf immer druck beim basar der
kampf überdruck doppel ist jetzt fertig
zu wassern sie führen gerade den lask
bzw dem body check durch den auftrag des
kampfes ist es sich unerkannt unter
wasser auf ein zielobjekt anzunähern und
das zielobjekt im anschluss aufzuklären
bereit
[Musik]
und wenn dich diese ausbildung beim
jahre waren nur interessiert und der
teil von unserem team werden willst
melde dich und kontaktdaten findest du
in der beschreibung
[Musik]
[Applaus]